in this video we're going to show you
how to get the black spindle which is
the evolved version of the black hammer
that we thought was lost forever but now
has made its way to the taken King as a
310 exotic sniper first and foremost
you're going to have to get a fire team
together because this mission is going
to be difficult ideally three if not at
least get one other person to help
revive what you're going to need to do
is a daily heroic loss to the light so
you have the rest of today hopefully to
see this video on to finish this quest
or you have to hope that it cycles back
into rotation because it doesn't work in
just normal story mode that has to be
the daily her own upon arriving into the
heroic strike just go ahead and run by
everything until you get to this ogre
you're going to have to fight this ogre
and damage him enough to the point where
he gets taken after he gets taken stand
near this rock and get the shards at
eris morn ones once the shadowy door
opens continue through the strike and
keep running there's no need to kill
anything here just make sure you don't
wipe on the way there finally you're
going to reach this circular room and
the chamber of the night we're on the
right side there's going to be a relic
coordinate with your fire team members
who's going to pick it up bring it to
the door and open it while that's
happening the other fire team members
can attack the night that's in the way
and kill some of the ads so that the
relic bear can get to the door easier
you don't have to kill these ads though
now run through the door and continue on
the path of the strike you're going to
make a right here and you're going to
have to deal with two relics this time
so if you have a third fire team member
of course have him kill the ads and
distract this wizard while the other two
of you go by these nights and grab the
relic to bring to the door be careful
here because if you all wipe you won't
have access to this secret area for the
Easter Egg have your relic holders put
it into the door wait for the door to
unlock and just keep running continue to
run because you won't need to do the
third set of relics what's going to
happen is you're going to end up in this
circular room here where you want to
continue to where you would normally
fight tanukhs on that strike continue on
until you get to the lift platform if
you want to go ahead and switch up your
specs switch up your guns or your
equipment etc go ahead and do that now
is it's a safe time to do that make your
way up the lift and you're going to
continue through the corridors and the
doorways until you reach the server room
once you access the server rooms here at
the doors you're going to trigger the
event the event is going to be timed and
you have ten minutes to get through it
your fire team cannot wipe because
otherwise you'll fail the mission and
you'll have to start all over again one
thing to note during the catch portion
of the mission is that there are no
instant revives there is a cool-down of
10 seconds or you can respond yourself
in about 20 seconds choose wisely on
wind revive or to tell your teammates to
respawn themselves because this event is
time and you only have ten minutes
you're gonna have to finish the rest of
this strike in those 10 minutes and kill
everything in your pack in the first
room the kind of server look in room
you're going to have to deal with three
nights a Centurion flight balls and adds
my fire team prioritize the flight balls
first and then we took care of the
nights and the Centurions and the ads
watch out of course they have shields
and they do a lot of damage so
coordinate your supers if you need two
grenades heavy weapons etc next you're
going to go through this slight corridor
and there's going to be enemies on your
left and your right including two
captains and some vandals be on the
lookout because they're going to throw
those blind balls so don't just stand in
the middle of the corridor here you're
going to reach the Walker room where
you're going to have to deal with flight
balls yet again three Wizards for
vandals snipers and then additional adds
acolytes etc my fire team prioritized
the flight balls first then we made our
way and killed each wizard next and then
we took out the Vandal snipers be
careful with the Vandal snipers because
they'll probably two shot you coordinate
who's gonna jump up and who's going to
stay below to take them out ideally you
want them to use your special taking
ability where they pop the bubble over
themselves and they don't have the
ability to shoot out of it going with
your shotgun or your fusion to finish
them off and drop down ideally you have
around seven minutes left here because
you're going to have to go through the
corridors that you would normally chased
annex through in the strike you're gonna
have to firstly deal with these two
failing TSA's and then after you deal
with them there's going to be a dual
bladed captain which you want a shotgun
or fusion rifle down right away and then
as you proceed through the corridor
there's going to be two more devoured
nights at the bottom of the stairs that
you have to be careful of because
they're going to start spraying their
fire all over the place here in the
final room where tanukhs would normally
be you're going to see the boss on the
middle platform where tanukhs normally
spots not only are you going to have to
deal with him you're going to have to
deal with blight balls and a bunch of
different ads that are going to spawn
the most annoying is probably the
Saiyans which are going to keep
duplicating themselves
so make sure to kill them I uses a low
supercell in this case because it did a
really good job against the Saiyans and
it kind of cleared the ads but of course
you can coordinate with your fire team
to pick out the signs with supers
heavies etc but you're also gonna have
to deal with devoured Knights Centurions
etc etc ideally you clear out the ads
fast enough so that you have limited
times where you can just dps the boss
the biggest thing to remember here is
that even if you kill the boss you have
to kill all the ads in the room in order
to complete the mission therefore the
best strategy is probably to take out
the flight balls and clear the ads so
that you can fully focus VPS on the boss
if not you definitely want to try to
just clear ads and shoot the boss at the
same time you can use the docking area
that you come in at as a nice safe spot
to kind of peek in and out to shoot
within cover you have to be careful with
this boss though because he has the
ability to throw the captain's blind
ball at you except he can do it three
times I would say try your best to clear
all the ads out do strong dps on the
boss rinse and repeat and once you do
that you're going to end up with your
shiny new black spindle which is going
to bring about all those nostalgic feels
of crota all over again or hopefully and
gorgoroth you're going to feel the wrath
of the black spindle good luck to all
you Guardians because today is the day
you're going to have to try to get this
because who knows when this quest will
show up in the daily heroic rotation
again so try to get your fire team
together try destiny lfg and of course
stay tuned to gamespot com for
continuing coverage of destiny
you